well we begin with the breaking news out
of the US White House Press Secretary
kayy mckin has tested positive for
Corona virus she's the latest among
president Donald Trump's in Inner Circle
to be infected well over the weekend she
gave several press briefings without
wearing a mask mckin was one of the many
people who attended Trump's Supreme
Court's nomination ceremony who have now
tested
positive and as for the US president's
health
he's also infected with Corona virus
doctors are set to decide in the coming
hours whether Trump is fit to be
released from hospital his chief of
staff says they're optimistic about his
prospects on Sunday Trump made a
surprise driveby for hundreds of his
supporters who are gathered outside the
hospital a doctor at the hospital where
Trump's being treated called it quote
irresponsible and astounding let's get
the latest now from our White House
correspondent Kimberly hulit she's
outside at Walter Reeds where president
Trump is being treated uh Kimberly let's
start with the press secretary she is
the latest high-profile figure in the
white house uh to contract the Corona
virus what sort of impact is this having
not just on the top team but also on the
the hundreds of people who work
alongside the president the press
secretary and all these senior
[Music]
officials well what this is doing is
introducing risks the latest is uh not
only a member of the White House Press
team to test positive for Co 19 but also
is a relative of Kaye McAn uh the latest
confirmation we have is that a member of
her press team Chad gilm Martin has
tested positive for Co 19 she uh works
very closely with Chad in what known as
upper press he is present many of the
White House Press briefings there
alongside the press secretary who we
also understand now has tested positive
for Co 19 and he is a relative of her
husband a cousin We Believe now in terms
of kayle's own diagnosis of testing
positive for coid 19 she confirmed that
that was the case through Twitter when
she released this statement and if you
want to pull it up we can work through
it together she says after testing
negative consistently every day since
Thursday I tested positive on Monday
morning while experiencing no symptoms
no reporters producers or members of the
press are listed as close contacts by
the White House medical unit she goes on
to defend the fact that she held press
briefings and says that she had no
knowledge that there was a positive test
result for the president's close advisor
hope Hicks and as a result she not only
held a press briefing on Thursday but
then held gaggles as recently as Sunday
now a gaggle is where she would stop in
the driveway uh where the Press Corp is
gathered and speak very informally often
no more than a meter apart so again the
prospect that there was risk introduced
to Extended members of the press pool is
significant now she defends this in her
statement she goes on with my recent
positive test I will begin the
quarantine PO process and we'll continue
working on behalf of the American people
remotely defending the fact that she
continued to work well not knowing that
she had coid 19 because she was trying
to get the latest information she says
about the president's health condition
to the American public but in doing so
she has not only put herself at risk but
also others uh meanwhile uh many people
are concerned about President Trump's
Health you can see large uh crowd of
supporters behind you there Kimberly and
president Trump is clearly itching to be
discharged from hospital but there's
still a lot of confusion as to his
current health status and how is the
president and is it likely he's going to
be discharged
today well uh we don't know because we
haven't had a briefing today Monday by
his medical team we were told that a
determination would be made today that
the president could be released as early
as a few hours from now the Press pool
was called to Walter Reed Medical Center
North of Washington DC in the US of
Maryland behind me uh and since then
they've been in a holding pattern not
only waiting for updates but waiting
potentially for the president to return
to the White House where he would have
the opportunity to be cared for in a
medical Suite inside the White House but
again we don't have any clarification on
that because there has been no briefing
what I can tell you is the president is
itching to get back on the campaign
Trail he released a Spate of tweets this
morning outlining his platform 29 days
in counting until November 3rd
presidential election and we know that
he's watching carefully his rival
Democratic Presidential nominee Joe
Biden who is hitting that coveted
Battleground State of Florida today and
also Senator Bernie Sanders hitting the
Battleground state of Michigan two
states that are badly needed by this
president if he hopes to win the White
House and yet he is not able to campaign
he is still in the hospital uh so
certainly this is probably agitating the
president who says according to his
chief of staff that he's feeling much
better he's positive and he's eager to
get back to the work of serving the
American people but at the same time
given his age given some of his
underlying health conditions we know
that he is still at risk for having
another downturn in his health as a
result of coid 19 okay well we await
that briefing from the medical team but
for now Kimberly Hut outside bter readed
thank
you